est-ce que maintenant j'ai tout ton
attention j'ai placé plusieurs bombes
dans toute la ville y compris autour de
l'Esplanade c'est une situation à
laquelle tu ne peux pas échapper ou à la
rideaux
tout le monde dehors
ne voit pas s'arrêter là
salut les filles mais dommages très
chers
ce que j'attends de toi c'est que tu les
voles
je suis le responsable de l'attentat à
la banque et j'en ai posé partout en
ville
pour voir ce qu'on a en face de nous
chef c'est tous les démineurs se
tiennent prêts à intervenir à quelqu'un
j'ai deux unités
[Musique]
avant qu'il y ait d'autres morts
aujourd'hui
feu vert
on a repéré une autre empreinte
thermique
toi de ça
hyper moi je te ment
i je crois que c'est qu'une simple
vengeance dites moi vous en êtes combien
de vie comptes-tu sacrifier
vous avez vu ma femme et ma fille oh